so what do border agents think when the
White House says the lifting of title 42
will not mean open borders Chris Cabrera
is the vice president of the national
border patrol Council and joins us now
Chris from your view what does the
ending of title 42 mean for this country
and our borders
you know ma'am uh listening to that last
clip with the press secretary that
that's got to be probably the dumbest
thing I've ever heard in my life
um you know lifting title 42 we're
already dealing with uh for the most
part open borders now and an
unprecedented uh
uh groups coming into the country and
that's the one thing that's that's the
the single uh strand that's holding
things together down here is title 42
and if you're going to remove it you
need to put something in its place but
if you just remove it outright and we're
just gonna get rolled over here Chris
what do you think is going to happen
here I mean you know you've got Joe
manchin saying yesterday he believes
that ultimately President Biden is going
to ask for an extension of this
um I don't know do you think there's a
possibility in the next 48 hours that
could possibly happen
you know there's a possibility that it
could happen but as far as the folks
that are coming across getting the word
I mean they're they're already on their
way I don't think they're going to stop
turning around and go back home
um this uh they've they've gotten way
too far with this and
they need to come up with with a real
solution instead of putting a Band-Aid
on a broken leg they need to come with a
real solution and finally fix this
because it's it's way past out of
control and anybody that says otherwise
is is just blind we're showing this
brand new uh video of a migrant
Processing Center El Paso Texas that
bill malusion just brought to us I mean
you see these things are over capacity
there's there's too many people for for
the number of people that are supposed
to be in these buildings to begin with
so I suppose the question to the White
House is if the borders aren't open then
what are they we see these massive
numbers of migrants flowing over our
borders let alone you know drugs pouring
over our borders what is it then
yeah and you know wait wait for 48 hours
and and you're really gonna see uh some
numbers coming in I guess the big
question is is it going to be uh
regulated to a few spots like Eagle Pass
and El Paso or are they going to hit
everywhere from Brownsville all the way
out to San Diego so we're we're in for
uh a rough couple of weeks right in time
for the Christmas holidays I guess Chris
what do you say to the white house uh
when Kareem Jean-Pierre just said well
this is on Republicans now they're
asking for 3.5 billion dollars in
additional border funding and if
Republicans don't come through on this
they're not taking this seriously enough
what's your response to that
you know man we've been dealing with
this since 2013. uh the government has
has failed every step of the way under
multiple presidents regardless of intent
to the the Congress just cannot seem to
put their partisanship aside and get
this done if this was a for-profit
company we would have been bankrupt
years ago this is just
um that the government's just inept they
can't get things done and either they
need to find a way to get things done or
they need to step aside and let somebody
in who's going to get things done
because the way they're handling
themselves is not good for the American
people it's just it's not good well we
see the pictures day in and day out and
we hear your frustration and urgency and
we continue to tell these stories the
president has yet to pay a visit down
there to the border to see what's
happening for himself uh there's been
bipartisan growing bipartisan calls for
him to do just that appreciate you
joining us Chris thank you
thank you ma'am hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else